oh well who could that be
[Applause]
[Music]
hello hi genie we miss you so
much surprised her co-host
on thursday returning to the reel to
give an update on her health
and the whole thing had adrian huffton
seriously in her feelings
wait i'm like legit crying over here
genie
what have you been doing during your
recovery time
we miss you so much the 37 year old
cheetah girl singer got emotional seeing
her co-host and friend
who has been taking time off the show
after having emergency throat surgery
earlier this month
garcelle i've been loving all your glam
on the gram
and basically i miss everybody like
crazy
oh genie that's so
the 41 year old had to have emergency
surgery after doctors found an
abscess that was blocking her airway the
potentially
life-threatening diagnosis forced her to
drop out of season 29 of dancing with
the stars
midway through the competition i'm
absolutely devastated that my journey on
desmond stars
has them this way she also had to take
some time off the reel
but it didn't stop her from tuning in to
see her girls
and i'm so thankful to have the reel to
keep me company
every day oh so she still watches us
okay thank you for watching
your show okay that's good
thank you for watching
taking care of jay oh yes he was on he
was
fabulous
jeannie's fiance jeezy chatted with the
ladies last week
he truly is the love of my life and he
opened up about the moment they knew
something was wrong
i just started to notice she was having
problems breathing and
she woke up one morning and got up
before me and i got up and went behind
her
and i saw her and she couldn't breathe
and i grabbed her immediately
took her to the emergency room he also
revealed what the doctors told her
following her diagnosis
the doctor immediately looked at her and
told her you know you're done with
dancing with the stars
you're done this is life-threatening and
you don't get it fixed right now
you could possibly lose your life and
for me
wow it was that was real you know and i
told her it was the hardest thing ever
because you guys know jenny more than i
do
um she's not a quitter she's a fighter
and just so you know right after surgery
she was trying to figure out how to get
back on that show and while her time on
dancing with the stars may be up
she's very excited to return to her day
job
what is she coming back is the question
i'm allowed to return to work next week
and can't wait being resting my voice
body so i'm ready you are even
long-winded in cards genie okay
girl long-winded in cars
that was three minutes oh my gosh she's
still going oh my god hold it down for
me real fam cause your
asian sensation is about to be back yes
[Music]
yes